[موسيقى
] مستقبل اختبار بعض
أقوى المحركات النفاثة في العالم موجود
هنا في منشأة دلتا الجديدة تمامًا
في أتلانتا ، وهذا مثير لأن هذه
هي أكبر خلية اختبار في
العالم وسنكون قادرين على تشغيلها
محركات 30 40 50 عامًا في المستقبل
بسبب الطريقة التي بنينا بها هذه
المنشأة ، يجب فحص المحركات التي تبقي
المسافرين في الهواء خلال عشرات الآلاف
من الرحلات الجوية يوميًا
بشكل منتظم للتأكد من أنها آمنة
للطيران وهذا هو  ما هو هذا المكان بالنسبة
لمحركات الخطوط الجوية أصبح أكبر
وأكبر لأننا نبني
طائرة ذات جسم عريض أكبر وأكبر وأكثر كفاءة ،
ويمكن لخلية الاختبار هذه التعامل مع ما يصل إلى 150.000
رطل من الدفع ، كل شيء هنا
عملاق مصمم للحفاظ على
قوة المحركات الهائلة بالداخل  الزنزانة وبعيدًا
عن المارة ، الجدران مصنوعة من
الخرسانة بسمك ثلاثة أقدام والأبواب
تزن أكثر من 300 ألف رطل ،
تم بناء مصعد ضخم في الأرضية حتى
يتمكن العمال من الوصول إلى المحركات التي
يمكننا القيام بها  يزيد وزن المحرك العادي عن ثمانية أطنان
عندما يمر بعملية إعادة البناء ،
كما تعلم ، في متجر في أي مكان
من 60 إلى 90 يومًا ، يتم تفكيك المحركات
بالكامل ، ويتم فحص جميع الأجزاء المفككة ،
ويتم
إعادة تجميع كل شيء ومن ثم يجب
أن يأتي إلى هذا المرفق إلى  يمكن
اختبارها ، يسمح لنا الاختبار بالتأكد من أن
درجات حرارة الزيت ، وضغط الزيت ،
يسرع العضو الدوار ، ودرجات حرارة غاز العادم ، تدفع
كل شيء إلى تلبية المعايير التي
نعلم أنه عندما نضعها على
متن الطائرة ، فإنها ستستمر
طالما أنه من المفترض أن نتوقع ذلك
المنشأة هي الرياضة ليس فقط دلتا
إيرلاينز ولكن مائة وخمسين
عميلًا آخر لدينا وهذا يجب أن
يعادل حوالي ألف 1200 محرك في
السنوات الثلاث إلى الخمس المقبلة
القصة الحقيقية حول هذه المنشأة
ليست أنها أكبر باتيل في
العالم  ولكن هذا هو ما يمثله ، فهو
إرث سيتركه كبار الفنيين لدينا
وراءه ، وكل ذلك يهدف إلى جعل
دلتا أكثر قدرة على المنافسة نظرًا لأن المزيد والمزيد
طائرات ركاب وركاب ركاب
تحلق في السماء
[موسيقى]